Albert ghiorso went home one night and
he said later he woke up in the night
and he said I know it should be proposed
that we named it seaborgium he made an
appointment to talk with Glenn Seaborg
the next day and Seaborg of course was
part of the discovery team so it was a
little touchy shall we say and he asked
Glenn well what do you think of this and
Glenn immediately said well I would
consider it more of an honor than the
Nobel Prize but I have to ask Helen
first Helen being his wife and he always
discussed everything with Helen and she
was a magnificent person so when he
asked her she said oh I think that would
be wonderful so he came back and said
Albert I I will go ahead go ahead with
the proposal one of the more popular
questions we've asked of our viewers is
would you rather win a Nobel Prize or
have an element named after you and now
we know from someone who had an element
named after what the answer is and you
know why Seaborg said that he said
because as long as there's chemistry and
a periodic table students will look at
that and say seaborgium I wonder what
that name is for and then they will find
out who I was and they will never know
that I want a Nobel Prize after all do
you remember who won the Nobel Prize in
1970 or 80 not a chance I want to talk
to you about seaborgium the element
named after the american physicist
chemist Glenn T Seaborg who was one of
the key chemists in the so-called
Manhattan Project the development of the
nuclear bombs or particularly the atom
bomb during the Second World War these
are some pins that we had
probably for one of the anniversaries
but as maybe it was a 65th anniversary
of the lab or something but anyway we
don't need much excuse to have
seaborgium pins made Brady has just been
to Berkeley where Seaborg worked in
California and has met some people who
knew him
I can't directly about forty years ago I
knew Glenn quite a while he used to
teach he was an extraordinarily good
lecturer he'd give a lecture on the
history of the periodic table the
elements he discovered then he'd go to
my office and I think I showed you the
picture of him lying on the couch and
you would see him extending beyond both
boundaries of this rather long couch in
my office take a quick nap go back get
the second lecture then the third
fantastic the kids were absolutely
fascinated at the end he'd spent five
minutes the presidents had known and it
started in the early days with the eight
presidents I've known the nine presence
I've known the very last that she gave
before he passed away was in 1996 I
think and then it was the eleven
presidents I've known the element itself
seaborgium was discovered long after
Seaborg has finished his research but
before he died the last thing is that at
the end the kids would crowd around him
with their books with the textbooks that
I designed and in the front of every
textbook of chemistry is typically a
periodic table and he would sign their
periodic tables and he stated for an
hour off the class doing that and his
comment would be kids this autograph is
not worth 50 bucks on the street but
hold on to it after I'm gone maybe worth
much more you can see here it's after at
the podium and dubnium and just before
Boreum now the difference between SIBO
and Rutherford and Bohr was that
Rutherfordton Bohr were long dead
when the elements had been named after
them but Seaborg had the element named
after him
while he was still alive and also in
this book I discovered I had this piece
of paper here which is seaborg's
obituary and it says at the bottom and
in 1997 that's two years before he died
Seaborg achieved what neither Einstein
nor Fermi had managed when an element
106 was named seaborgium it was the
first time a living scientist had had an
element's named after him they had
forgotten that some scientists were
women who like Meitner and curium who
also had an element's named after her
but Brady has told me that this may not
be true and that einsteinium may have
actually been named their butts not
publicly before Einstein died but I'm
not a specialist in this area but some
of you who do that diving into the
Internet may find out whether this is
true and can put it in a comment Albert
ghiorso proposed it for the discoverers
sent it into I you pack and he thought
that's all there was going to be to it
well I knew better having to had some
dealings with IU pack and so first they
decided that you could not name an
element after a living person the IU
pack Commission was restructured with
some new people and so forth and we
urged them to check and see and there
was actually no such rule at all and so
then finally I guess finally it got
approved in 1997 and it got approved
soon enough so Seaborg could stand at
the periodic table like this and point
to his element and we were so happy that
he was still alive and
good point here this is seaborgium I
think the element itself seaborgium is
not a very important element but it is a
very good memorial to a scientist who
probably has discovered more of the
elements recently than any other
scientist I was so happy it was
fantastic it was almost as good as if
I'd been a Discoverer not quite only
very small amounts of seaborgium a few
atoms will have been made but just like
the other elements in the periodic table
you can look at where it is in the
periodic table it is in the same group
as chromium molybdenum and tungsten
tungsten is one of the densest elements
one could guess that seaborgium will be
if you got a large enough lump would be
a very dense element it would probably
have quite a high melting point you
could make filaments of lightbulbs out
of seaborgium and they would probably
burn brighter than if you've have a
tungsten halogen lamp you can probably
also say that it would react with carbon
monoxide to make so-called carbon nails
but all of this is theoretical because
the elements has very short lifetime it
is highly radioactive
so it's chemistry would effectively be
dominated by the radiation that it gives
out but nevertheless is quite fun to
speculate
there were wooden steps that went from
campus up this big hill you just came up
and when he was younger he would go down
to campus with me and then we would walk
back up and he would be striding along
like this and I'd be going I think they
decided they were too dangerous now you
have to do everything for health and
safety but it was quite a trick starting
from here going all the way down to
campus trying to keep up with Glenn
Seaborg who's six foot three when I'm
five foot one I was going like this all
the time
it was much younger then you're still
pretty fit by the sounds of it then you
fit over me I think if you swim every
day